gott berufen
dabei ist luca und herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen blog auf
meinen kanal aerospace 13 eingeblendet
hier reagieren heute zusammen auf momo
das ist dieses komische gruselige potro
fieldings sie sagt das allerdings dass
ich und ich denke auch jeder andere
mensch der mary prozent ein brötchen
besitzt er weiß dass das ganze pack ist
und deswegen reagiert nicht auf mono an
sich also ich werde euch das ganze mal
erklären falls nicht was diese person
hier übrigens ist und warum sie so
schrecklich aussieht und was überhaupt
diese ganze scheiße soll das ganze jetzt
mal kurz erläutern
die sache ist allerdings dass wir nicht
auf diese truppe an sich reagieren
werden sondern auf eine deutsche youtube
in die mal wieder komplett übertrieben
hat mit den reaktionen auf dieses ding
dafür habe das ganze allerdings nur 210
ist
totes tier eigentlich elektrisch oder
mit norman wirth vorbeikommende
kommentare leute weil es in meinen blog
so ich erzähle immer richtig viele bei
mädchen wirklich nicht viel was in
meinem leben gesehen was sie verteilte
wohneinheiten habe die therapie der wahl
bei euch weiß ich eigentlich gar nicht
sich wieder einmal ein bisschen besser
kennenlernen allerdings klopapier oder
sechs oder acht lange wurden ja
klopapier aber hin oder her geht's
bereits mittel eingeblendet wie
reagieren heute auf momo ich hasse
dieses ding bevor ich euch das ganze
allerdings erst mal erklären und dann
auf die youtube reagiere die ich meine
erstmal ganz kurze info uns war wird das
nicht das einzige sein was diesen blog
passieren mit sondern super und ich
werden auch nach paris waren hinzu das
ist das ist ein zug unser zug fährt
genau in einer stunde 15 und ich muss
noch auf nur reagieren
müll rausbringen wohnung auf wollen mit
ihren auch noch sachen packen also muss
ich jetzt bisschen durch zunächst einmal
um euch ganz kurz zu erklären was diese
puppe namens momo überhaupt esm sie
sieht so aus also echte gar nicht mal so
schön eigentlich und es ist ein wesen
was sich in die whatwg kontakte von
verschiedenen whatsapp usern quasi
einnistet und dann mysteriöse komische
nachrichten verschickt und es wird
gesagt dass wir spanien kommt oder aus
japan aber das weiß man nicht so ganz
genau diese komische puppe an sich gibt
es zwar wirklich also das ist irgendwie
so eine japanische esskultur da
irgendwie sowas jedoch ist es sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich und eigentlich
unmöglich dass es diesen account
wirklich gibt und dass diese puppe halt
irgendwelchen leuten komischer
nachrichten schreibt allerdings ist so
was für youtuber natürlich gefundenes
fressen und sie machen dann irgend
welche fake sachen daraus wie
beispielsweise die 24 stunden challenges
wo leute einfach nur ja keine ahnung ein
oder zwei stunden irgendwo waren und
deshalb nur so zusammengeschnitten haben
oder die 83 wo gesagt wurde hey mache
niemals m3 und nachts dies und diesen
dann passiert irgendwie was andere leute
einfach die uhr umgestellt
ja genau das gleiche findet quasi auch
gerade bei momo stadt ich wollte dazu
eigentlich gar kein video machen weil
dass es für mich unglaublich bescheuert
ist diese komplette thematik und zu
dieser drei und nachts kaka da hab ich
mich auch nachher nachhinein darüber
lustig gemacht
das jedoch hat eine deutsche youtube
wird und wenn dieser ganzen sache war
wieder komplett übertrieben genauso wie
damals bei dem drei uhr trend und bei
den 24 stunden sachen und deswegen ja
meine damen und herren reagieren wir
heute auf rebecca will das hier ist der
youtube kanal von rebecca willi zu
videos hoch die eigentlich immer das
gleiche ziel haben und was ich auch
besonders geil finde ist ihre
rechtschreibung und grammatik bei den
titeln mache virtuellen schleim mit
meinem handy freund kostenlos ins kino
bringen schlau oder versuche so zu sein
großes herz eine sekunde was würdest du
tun
ich kann den deutschkurs anbieten
allerdings ist das ganze ja nicht weiter
schlimm sie machte ihren videos inhalt
gravierende fehler aber darum sollte
heute gar nicht gehen sondern darum sie
hat tatsächlich sechs ganze videos zu
dieser moro kacke hochgeladen als
youtuber ist man natürlich jemand der
sich für trends interessiert und
natürlich auch mit trends mehr oder
weniger mit geht weil es einfach die
masse interessiert bei mir was
beispielsweise bei diesem ppp also das
war dieser komische typ der irgendwie
pineapple päppelten gemacht hat
apropos da habe ich ein video zu gemacht
uns einfach kurz zu erklären und zu
sagen was das für eine scheiße ist bei
der drei und nachts kacke habe ich auch
ein video zu gemacht um auch zu sagen
was für eine scheiße ist 24 stunden habe
ich auch nur hochgenommen und jetzt bei
momo dachte ich mir kommen mache ich gar
nichts aber sechs videos rebecca ein
bisschen
allerdings würde ich sagen wir schauen
uns das ganze mal an erstmal natürlich
auch starke bewertungen hier 57.000 zu
16.000 ich habe mich schon wieder angst
vor diesem video glaubt gar nicht mit
angst ich habe ihr glaubt gar nicht wie
angst ich habe also das angebot mit dem
deutschkurs steht noch an der stelle
allerdings wie immer bei meinen
reactions ich kenne rebecca dinge nicht
persönlich ich habe noch nie mit ihr
gesprochen ich habe noch nie mit ihr
geschrieben noch nichts mit ihr gemacht
deswegen kann ich sie natürlich nicht
hier als person bewerten sondern ich
bewerte nur die videos die sie
hochgeladen hat rebecca fall zu dass sie
70 will ich in keiner form beleidigen es
kann sein dass du ein sehr sehr sehr
sehr netter mensch ist ein content den
feierlich nicht so aber ich habe es mal
weiter
es stimmt was ob das wirklich stimmt
was soll denn passieren jeden fall die
rede von moro leute ich halte portiert
schon davon gehört habt auf jeden fall
sollte also die so aus als hätten wir
schon sagen diese dinge schon hart
ekelhaft wie lagert hier jetzt auf jeden
fall die ganze zeit hat die ganze zeit
die gleiche kamera perspektive ist auch
kein großartiger schnitt drin
die sache ist da jetzt mio
die person schreibt etwas chinesisches
und zwar drei mal exakt die gleiche
nachricht und fünf mal die gleiche
nachricht ist sechsmal die galten sie
mal die gleiche nachricht jetzt kommt
wahrscheinlich das achte mal gleiche
nachricht oder ja genau da kommt ist das
achte mal mensch das ist doch völlig
real jetzt gerade das passiert auch
wirklich einmal die gleiche nachricht
das recht auf ich muss mir erst mal kurz
ein paar kommentare hier durchlesen
haben wir müssen keine angst haben in
den comics seien die sicher hier gibt es
essen
ertrinken
und wieder rechtschreibfehler überall
als ich bietet es nicht für rebecca an
ich würde es auch für die community
anbieten sondern deutschkurs mit lukas
so summa summarum jux eigentlich ja ist
klar ist ob ihr das alle glaubt also
eine schauspielschule hast du definitiv
nicht besucht das ist echt eine gefahr
für die menschheit solche eine
volksverdummung kann man doch nicht frei
herumlaufen lassen schlechter gestellt
als erwartet das einzige was mir angst
macht wir zeigen was mich schockiert
dass die tatsache dass sie wirklich so
viele abonnenten hat denken wirklich
menschen dass das real ist er herr
becker als ich studiert im achten
semester japanische letzten nachricht
hat ist nicht gefragt ob die sojasauce
über deine nudeln drüber haben willst du
da die bei separat im becher ich finde
du siehst momo ähnlich also das war
schon krankheit ist hier also schlimmer
kann man ein video nicht faken du siehst
schon aus wie momo also denken kannst
und schauspielkunst auch nicht so sein
ding
also ja ich glaube ich bin ich der
einzige der denkt dass wieder ein
bisschen scheiße gemacht hat also sie
geht jetzt in den google übersetzer
also diese nachricht die mode geschickt
habe anscheinend nicht mit der sojasauce
am sondern ich kann dich finden
mal schauen wie die rebecca darauf jetzt
reagiert rebecca wetter beruhigt beruhig
dich das ist nur eine freundin oder dein
freund alles gut ich hab da übrigens der
empfehlung für dich dass sie jetzt so
eine schauspielschule für anfänger in
berlin
die haben so termine der nächste termin
ist am 24
achten also in sechs tagen rebecca
könntest du ja mal dahin gehen und ein
bisschen üben vielleicht kannst du das
nächste mal ein bisschen überzeugen da
eine million abonnenten verarschen
ich will nicht dass sie irgendwie denkt
dass ich 24 stunden im barbie auto
eingesperrt da wissen wir schon wollen
wir hier sind ich will nicht dass es so
rüberkommt als würdig rebecca will
hassen oder irgendwie so es geht ja nur
um ihre videos lisa mono sache um die
anderen videos schaue ich mir jetzt
nicht an aber die können ja ganz cool
sein ich meine sonst hätte sie haben
nicht über eine million abonnenten aber
hier wirklich sieben videos dazu
hochzuladen finde ich schon ein bisschen
krank m vor allem dann unter dem ersten
video ja schon tausendfach oder 10.000
fach geschrieben wurde dass sie alle
verarscht und einfach nur schlecht
spielt dieses ganze video sei aber auch
nicht so negativ seien leute er mich
wollte nur auch mal kurz was zum homo
sagen weil
viele leute haben herr luca denkst du
dass momo echt ist ich denke mir habt
ihr mehr gehirnzellen als der
waschmaschine
das ist natürlich nicht echt leute also
ich meine wenn ich jetzt hier auf meinem
handy gucken ja gott beruft micha milch
ist gift allerdings will ich an der
stelle meine reaktion auf dieses
komische skulptur monster aus japan
namens momo auch beenden beziehungsweise
eine reaktion auf rebecca wegen war es
eigentlich mehr oder weniger an der
stelle nochmal anzumerken ich habe
nichts persönlich gegen rebecca will ich
wollte nur auf ihn konzentrieren bei
gott oder paris fährt einer halben
stunde habe es geschafft in diesem sport
express nach paris
hallo wir sind in paris angekommen
der hauptbahnhof oder paris nord oder
posiert auf dem weg zum hauptbahnhof gar
nicht mal so schön aus ehrlich gesagt
auf jeden fall den plätzen über und fans
gewonnen
und jetzt draußen unserer unterkunft
hier in paris angekommen
ich hasse diese riesigen land touren
immer deswegen zeige ich euch das
einfach im schnelldurchlauf der
eingangsbereich das schönste bild in
dieser wohnung das wohnzimmer ganz viele
kerzen die genau so litten die mein
leben nämlich gar nicht die kirche ein
tolles keep calm and drink champaign
kissel ich hasse es wenn andere youtuber
ist auch mit einem start so lud das
schlafzimmer ein telefon aus dem
sechzehnten jahrhundert das feld unten
gesendet direkt ab als im april aber not
least unser kleiderbügel staubsauger
scheiß raum
das gute ist sogar ein bisschen rot
liegt ja einfach noch so eine kiwi um
[Gelächter]
schon echt schön hier ist ein turm schon
klasse viele menschen und juden nicht
googeln wo der nächste reise ist wir
haben halt hunger warum
juli starb der eifel tomaten kurzschluss
jeder auto fan jetzt jetzt nicht mehr
einkriegen
es steht ein bugatti veyron ein renault
bleibt einfach bleibt direkt da stehen
eine g klasse 6 x 6 und ein bugatti
veyron nebeneinander
hier kannst du ein foto von mir von der
auszumachen video genom browser bei 530
ist meine bürgerpflicht ein getränk und
jude ist erdnüsse
mit diesem zitat ich dem heutigen blog
ist allerdings auch beenden weil der
damen und herren wir sind wieder zu
hause in unserem erp abbey angekommen
und werden nun auch schlafen gehen
vorher natürlich noch sagen angucken
wenn euch dieser blog hier allerdings
gefallen hat dann das gerne mal ein
leichter freunde und wollt ihr dass ich
im nächsten block quasi mal einen
richtigen blog machen wir hier sind die
blogs immer so dass ich morgens wegen
etwas filme dann geht es um das thema
quasi wie beispielsweise heute meine
direkte logo und dann kommt der rest des
tages also wie wird nach paris gefahren
sind und so weiter und so fort denn ihr
wollt dass ich morgen mal so einen
typischen youtube blog macher also quasi
einen blog wo ich einfach den ganzen tag
meinen tag zeige dann schreibt man die
kommentare paris und dann wird der
nächste block war sie nur paris sein
dass eine hässliche lampe und ich bin
jetzt auf dem motto
[Musik]